hello and welcome to this video pro
Mateo 77 nope no name Argentinian
Argentinian set the right flag it's not
a kosher con Knight c3 here anyway it's
not bad a three input I wouldn't have
minded to transpose to her to an Enzo
which I know quite well anyway um 24 26
so we are about evenly rated
h6 I've lost to this guide two times
before and see what happens here in this
game doesn't ring a bell though I have
no idea what happened in those games um
okay yeah keep it keep it simple he's
got one slight issue that is the knight
on c6 which is misplaced but um yeah
this is the usual way to correct that
issue let's see wonder if couldn't be
five as a move just to attack just to
attack things 95 could also be can also
be an idea
just trying to provoke something here on
the queenside b6 for example it's not a
move that black wants to play um but
take b7 hear em am I getting my queen
trapped I don't see it so I'll take it I
don't see how it wraps the Queen
otherwise this is just a good trade as
the c6 bonus is weak um yeah how to do
that 95 maybe potential OC for this
night f4 so probably start with this
move
Chandler same two times before doesn't
ring a bell them would it all let's see
you
there's not easy for black the sea point
is weak and there are no day for ideas
this 94 and then we'll see one
okay Luke be one he goes black ghettos
to be eight okay that does not help
would be three as a possible move for
him to activate hmm not quite sure how
to play this here I just put the CM i
also want to be ready for 94
seems he wants to go to d6 here try for
Luke c5
i keeps keeps us position actor found
that sets good defense let's see
ninety-five would like to trade the a
plans against one another but I don't
think I'll manage that i think i should
get c6 and then I still have a and D
porn to play against looks you for maybe
but rook is success in is a good move
yeah that's annoying actually and rook
c8 is pretty awkward now
wow isn't that winning a piece that was
the main threat I thought you had to go
f6e anyway black reasons jeremy tough
position i mean this is this must be
better for white to some degree but it's
not clear to what degree c six weeks c5
is a week square yeah so white must be
better but it's not as i said i'm not
not quite sure how much Jim I mean this
I think kept some some kind of an edge
Jim 97 unsure that it might give up
something because he six is weak and I'm
not sure that I want to trade it against
the airport the computer wants to play
this route be a bag now I very nice it's
very nice now like now cannot trade as
this would loosen that would lose
something a 95 and I'm winning the
airport thats its also winning the game
I guess so he has to go away with the
rook somewhere and then I've conquered
the beef I'll it's it's it's fantastic
achievement and now yeah g4 kini to king
of one king it too slowly I've got
complete control here now black it's
just condemned to passive waiting it's
very strong that's stronger was a lot
stronger than what I did he takes and
now he has to okay he can give this this
loses he can you can give the cheetah
and f5 this is what the engine was
giving
and a form
with equal play this is what the
computer gives funny hey quality some
equality very tough okay well then then
I guess I can be happy with I mean I
can't be happy anyway if that he
overlooked ok it but it doesn't seem
that I had much if he if he doesn't the
a porn is probably probably too strong
so the key is this this is a lot
stronger look back and now go for this
is a very strong maneuver very strong
improvement by the engine okay well
thanks for watching